so dan when you and i spoke in early
2020 i asked you you know do you think
there's a chance that you would ever
reconsider going back to the role of
jack thornton
would you be down to come back in a
much foreign of course i really think
that we manifested this you are back as
jack thornton in the upcoming when hope
calls holiday film so how did this whole
thing even come about i think maybe we
did manifest it for sure but there was
definitely a lot of um
a lot of
messages and and hope from the fans
that that this character would come back
in some capacity and so
you know i got to give credit to laurie
uh laurie
it was her idea essentially she called
me yeah and asked if i'd be uh down for
it and i was like working with you again
of course the most important thing for
me was you have to honour the fans you
have to honour the character and you
have to honor elizabeth's storyline on
the other show what you'll find is that
it's
a beautiful
scene
done in the right way
in my opinion
and i i just know the fans are gonna
really
really get a kick out of seeing seeing
that character back on their screens for
sure doing a scene with lori again i
mean that was like it was like nostalgia
plus yeah i was gonna ask i mean did it
feel like
oh my gosh are we are we back on the set
of one calls the heart again
i gotta say yeah it really felt like uh
it felt so natural
but there was also a lot of like hugs
and like i'm so glad we're getting to do
this so grateful to be here doing this
again together we facetimed erin and the
three of us had a moment together
i feel like it was it was bittersweet
because you know we were we were really
happy that we laurie and i were working
together again and then we facetimed
erin and she was like i'm so happy for
you guys i wish i was there
so that and that would have been great
you know like we we had talked about
this multiple times like working
working all together again in some
capacity
um
that that may or may not happen but the
feeling is is there can i ask what goes
on during that facetime what do you guys
talk about and what are the feelings
that are you know kind of rushing
through your brain there was a lot of
like
miss you love you
wish you were here i felt grateful for
even just working with these great women
it's no secret that there's still so
much nostalgia amongst the fans um to to
see you with aaron krakow and laurie
lachlan together on screen one day um
i'm curious are there conversations are
there ideas bubbling up about how the
three of you could reunite one day as a
trio on screen yeah i would i would just
love
in any capacity to work with these
amazing women again so i i did have a
couple of conversations with laurie and
we talked about some behind the scenes
collaboration and i would work with
aaron in a heartbeat the idea of us
doing a
movie together a christmas movie a
rom-com whatever
in any capacity i just think that's a
no-brainer i think that would stop that
but you know we'll leave that up to the
movie gods and see what happens
so we don't quite know
in what capacity we're gonna see jack
again i assume it's going to be a
flashback but all i know is that we do
see you
in the red surge back on screen once
again as jack thornton so what did it
feel like to put on that uniform and
embody this beloved character once again
the creator
brian bird when i put that surge on and
walked on set and saw him there i just
walked up to him and hugged him and said
thank you thank you mate i felt a lot of
gratitude and then i put my game face on
and got professional because i had a job
to do you know
yes
did it feel surreal i mean what did it
feel like to walk
wearing this you know this uniform that
holds so much um pride and prestige i
forgot how hard the boots were to put on
you know so
i was like oh yeah that's right the boot
you think you forget that stuff you hold
on to all the good stuff right right
right but i walked on set and
and laurie saw me and she
got
you know emotional about it i got
emotional about it
the people that were involved with when
calls are hard producers and whatnot
we're there just like oh man
was this a was this a tearful moment
were people like you know shedding a
little nostalgia tear or two
i i definitely had glassy eyes at one
point yeah i did it's meaningful to me
you know i mean i don't know if i
can get that across but it is you know
it's really meaningful this character
and these people yeah and i love that
you said that um the way that this whole
thing even came about was because
your old pal laurie picked up the phone
and thought of you for this opportunity
i mean what did it feel like to share
the screen with laurie once again after
you know so much history shared between
the two of you no one laurie's a great
actor she she can just turn it on and
this was such an important scene to both
of us that we really we took it
seriously we took it really seriously
laurie is just one of those people that
has so much goodness and positivity and
kindness for so many people if you
know her as well as i do then you know
how just
genuine loving kind
um and caring she is with every single
person that she comes in contact with
she's a real deal so when we're on set
working together was like you know it
was just great to see my friend again
nothing has made me happier than being
your mom
you mean it
with all my heart
you doing this in in my humble opinion
kind of feels like a love letter to this
super super dedicated and loyal
fan base do you think that that's fair
to say you know did you do this um as a
as a big thank you to the hearties who
have shown you love and support these
hearties and the fans of this show are
just the most and we talk about this all
the time you know this i mean they're
just the most loyal
fans
in the world
and me doing this was you know
i had i had a number of reasons to to do
this
um i felt like it was
a
really nice poignant way to say goodbye
to this character is it really goodbye
or do you think that the door's open to
return in a more frequent capacity i
have been approached in casual ways from
people that are involved with these
projects like let's let's do something
more let's do something like how
if you can give me a good way to do it
that makes sense
then
i'll be open to listening so
who
knows what will come
um but i'll just leave it a bit i've
discovered a new meteor shower and i'm
here to watch it here
i like spending time with you nothing
more complicated or scientific than that
i'm so excited about your new film a
christmas star it's so cool to see you
opposite sarah canning you guys had
really tremendous chemistry what was it
like working with her
yeah sarah's great you know it was easy
when you
when you work with an actor that's like
a really giving actor like like i am uh
and collaborative
um it just makes it just makes the whole
experience really pleasurable and you
also have another wonderful co-star your
on-screen daughter uh what a sweet bond
your character has with his daughter in
in one scene i i loved you actually like
braided her hair
that was my idea actually was it really
yeah you know juliet hawk
who played celeste was just a just a
ball of
sunshine and positive energy yeah she's
a special kid she's just a special kid
and i i loved
you know playing a dad actually for the
first time in my career so
it's great i was just gonna say no i
know that you are a very proud dog dad
but actually playing a dad on screen for
the first time i mean did that give you
kind of like the feels maybe the itch to
uh start a little family of your own
yeah i'm definitely like uh i i have
that um vision for uh nadia's in our
future but um
we're doggy parents at the moment and i
i guess i had that feeling uh
you know when when you when you're
acting you're acting but um
but certainly when my my niece was was
born
something went like oh yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna have kids
one day you know how many
i mean one one healthy child is good two
three but you know i don't have a a
number i don't think i want maybe three
is a good number because then you can
all fit into one car how does nadia feel
about it and i mean
what does it mean to her to see you
getting to play a father on screen we
we've had these conversations um before
i played at that anyway you know like
yeah you know it's like kind of before
you tie the knot you're like all right
what do you want feel like so yeah so
we've kind of kind of covered all of
that i think she thought it was uh
really sweet but she sees me with kids
anyway like you know we have kids in our
neighborhood so
i'm like
kind of king of the kids around here
i know that you and nadia tied the knot
congratulations
um but you know pre-pandemic i know your
plan was to have this like balinese
extravaganza halfway around the world
with all your friends and family and
unfortunately you know circumstances put
a halt on that so you know now that
people are starting to travel a little
bit are you guys in the process of
revisiting this like bali extravaganza i
think we're gonna
we're gonna try and do it next year
um we're just gonna have to see how
everything's going but i think you know
i think next year might be
the right time to do it you know now
that you are husband and wife i'm
curious what do the holidays mean to you
do you guys have special traditions that
you look forward to doing together now
that you are really a unit i'm jewish
she's catholic and so we sort of come
together and have chrismaker i guess
we've got a tree in our living room with
a star of david on the top of it so you
know i i kind of accommodate the
christmas decorations with a little
touch of
my uh my traditions actually this is the
first time that we're gonna be flying to
poland
and um
locking it down with uh with the family
nadia's family over there we'll be
having a polish christmas you know are
you gonna learn all the polish
traditions
yeah i think so i mean
nadi tries to teach me you know polish
at home basic phrases
i love you give me a hug give me a kiss
okay let's hear a little let's hear a
little
kohang arizona that means i love you my
wife
good very good oh she's teaching you the
important phrases i see oh that's it it
defuses any tension at all just just
drop with a bit of polish in there great
you